[Music]
C
you know I I am a teacher
okay and I I teach all type of people
okay the
disadvantage and the
high on and on okay there so many people
that would like to ask questions so
question we have commun there also
my answer to you my answer to you as a
Muslim we prce our constitutional right
to have the freedom of worship
regardless like it or like
[Applause]
it not apologize americ we do not
apologize for being a Muslim and we do
not apologize for being
Amer there
isy is gone there is
he's gone he son is right he's a Judas
that's what he
[Applause]
[Music]
is
question I understand they rich I know
there's been problems with the local mon
because the worshipers feel they have to
come outside spread
prayer on the sidewalk PR this causing
problems for people were trying to walk
through well things like not be taking
place
here
will will be
conducted yes everything will be inside
next
question this is in the Quran the Quran
commands Muslims to fight nonim until
they are exterminated and Islam is the
only religion in the world he goes not
to say kill the non Muslim wherever you
find them capture them them Ling away
for them and them a good friend of mine
is a
Muslim his own words for me is Dennis
Islam is a religion of violence we don't
want to
[Applause]
be
at the last meeting
meeting
[Music]
came Muslim in thee area that's why you
guys build the M here all right my
question to you is just said
that said that first praying out on the
street in the M now there's 1200 in in
this South area
ofia 600 families men and women kids and
they come to prayer services that is
not
Modi how many people can you get into
that building to pray more Muslims show
up during a prayer meeting during a pray
service
overflow no the answer is the number of
building the number of people will enter
the building is the same number will be
allowed by the building department how
many is that I have no idea we didn't do
anything inside here we didn't have the
building
[Music]
[Applause]
as
[Music]
my my name is sh I am I am Muslim and as
a concern amican and not believe in VI I
have a question for you this m will you
be educating the communities who are
concerned about this love will you be
able to educate them about the different
interpretation
like who are responsible to the B and
you see in Iraq Afghanistan the RO to
teach the community
about all the different
interpretation be able to do that to
show that not just one side who teaches
violence but they are aspect of this
want to preach teach and other to
hijack and teach
violence to do
[Applause]
that the role of every mask in the area
that the mask is the source of education
and it's the source
of of defining and having the
relationship with the communities as
neighbors so we need to build good
relation with our neighbors whoever they
are even if they hate us it doesn't mean
that we have to respond the same in one
of in
one in one of in one of the that we have
about Jesus he was walking with his
disciples and one of the people was
started cursing at him and Jesus was
telling him thank you thank you one of
his disciples asked him why are you
telling him that and Jesus looked at his
disciple and told him everyone SP of
what he has thank you very much
[Applause]
foring my name is and I have questions
and one and my first question is if m is
one of
FBI why recognize Nationwide as a
community Serv organization this is my
first my second is if m is terrorist why
Police
Department run EV
[Music]
and my comment is as a in America I te
is that you have to respect and accept
the other and I wouldn't BR myself
because I if I know that I'm going to
hear many many that I don't like come to
here thank
you thank you n has been having
the since
199 for 17 years and our ability to this
means that we are abiding by the
Constitution and by the law of the
United States of America and we will
continue to do so thank
[Applause]
you investigative project um Marty brace
himself said in a Muslim Gathering that
fusion centers which are responsible for
National Security are keeping an eye on
what Boy Scouts are doing Mass Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts um so and and I
believe his name was Mr Lambert for
Scouts of America has said that that
kind of activity that Bray was
encouraging uh will stop or or mass will
lose its its
U affiliation
with and but I have a real quick
question um Mr s you said that in the S
Island Advance that um investiga project
anyone can put anything on the internet
can you point out once specific item
that investiga project has put out here
say that is incorrect and specifically
what is incorrect about it thank you
okay as part of the as part of
the I think as an indicated Community
when we see an information we need to
look at the credibility of the
information if theist if the terorist
list has no list for the name of mes and
somebody has a blood and voting whatever
he is voting as an educated Community
which one you seek your information from
I'm asking for something specific in the
masier that you can look at
investigative project website we just
like to know one item that you can state
is incorrect and untrue that's all we
want to know since you question the
veracity of
Ip all right we're waiting
for
good evening I'd like to know if it's
not a fact that in 2006 in Denver
Colorado a Muslim shot four co-workers
and a police officer saying it Al choice
in 2007 in Salt Lake City a Muslim went
on a shooting rampage at a mall
targeting people buying down FR card
kills five as it decided the kran I'd
like to know if it's not fact that in
2009 in Little Rock a muslim with
religious motives shoots a local Soldier
to death inside a recruiting center I
like to know it's not a fact that in
2009 in Tex a Muslim psychiatrist runs
down 13 unarmed soldiers while yelling
praises to Allah let's not forget the
man that tried to blow up the plane and
blow up his Pro instead and all the
other terrorist attacks that were done
in the name of Allah not in the name
name of Jesus and not in the name of
Moses tell me why I shouldn't be
[Applause]
afraid any Act of Terror any act of
violence both
killings both
killing those killings those killings
are not represented representing Islam
are not representing the true teaching
of of Islam neither the American Muslim
Community thank
you we got another 25 minutes
[Music]
people my name is Bill finan I returned
this past December from
Afghanistan
[Music]
[Applause]
your two questions
questions all right for the Civic
leaders of the community and for the um
new members of the
community will you work to benefit the
[Music]
community yes absolutely my
question
myun
[Music]
[Applause]
work
[Music]
I'm a concerned citizen of the United
States of America I'm concerned for my
country for my family for my community
okay um about been 9 years almost since
911 it's only been 9 years okay many
members of this community have lost
loved ones okay and P is still there and
and it hurts okay so you have to
understand that first and foremost okay
as for um investigative project you say
that you know it's not based on fact and
I want to know why is it that that
they're praised okay they're praised by
former ch
terrorism from the FBI and from the um
National Security Council why is that if
it's not based on any kind of fact that
these people actually said that you know
PR
Steve Steve okay and my other question
is that you say you believe in Jesus
okay I that's wonderful do you believe
that he the Son of God you believe that
he the
Christ up a lot tonight so I like stand
on
that we we do believe in God as one God
and we do believe in all Messengers
Abraham Moses Jesus
mam be upon all we do believe that all
of them including Abraham including
Moses including Muhammad and Jesus the
are human they neither God nor Son of
God we believe that he is a human We
Believe Muhammad is human they were
given the message of God to guide
Humanity to the right
path you don't believe that okay but
what about my question investiga project
and the people who praise
[Music]
it the the in the investigative project
attack every Muslim leader in the United
State
including people who are preaching
motivation and balance such as
IM such as Dr Jamal such as others
people who have contributed to the
wellbeing of the American
society
[Music]
himself had himself ran a program in his
neighborhood against Dr Jamal who's a
scholar everybody everybody has
investigated project everybody if you
are Muslim activist or a Muslim leader
they attack you those people have been
living in the United stat of America for
10 and 20 and 50 years amazingly they
have been attacked by the investiga
projects and none of them was none of
them was convicted in a criminal or an
according to the law of the United
States that in itself indicates that
this is a plan for
portray Islam
[Applause]
andl hello my name is Ellen I grew up in
mid Beach I attend stary school sa here
and I live in the community today my
concern personally is that K is part of
the parish which includes the school the
church the condent all of it breaking
this up and selling it to making it a
mosque is disruptive to the community
itself what's to prevent you from
purchasing this building as wellas this
is not looking at for our backs who
[Applause]
is and that's basically to the civic
association as well how are we going to
prevent this going forward how do you
stop how do you stop the Le it didn't
feel like the leing sales it felt
[Music]
like and as this is done
all we know is that the contract
[Music]
signed suprem
cour that's as far as we know the York
Das is not responding to what
V now I don't know if anybody saw
today's article it came in late this
afternoon where the arch dasis is
denying anything that they have nothing
to do with the stale that it was all
father FY they
are it's in
today I'm just the
[Music]
messenger next
question next question next
question
all
right everybody
else father can you come up here I know
you guys traveled a long time to get
here and you've been waiting and they've
been asking to
[Music]
speak
wasn't come up and just say some
[Music]
listen I don't understand excuse
me are we are we Stu these people
were these people were
[Music]
invited excuse
[Applause]
[Music]
me what had to
say pleas were invited to be here I am
from b
[Music]
i
I have a
word we have met we have
30,000
[Music]
m
I'm not paid I live in Bay Ridge I am
part of the unity task force with Father
OT team our rabbis our Manas and our
eons we have lived in peace for 18
years we know the lost on 18 on bth
Avenue for 10 years we know Mohammed and
we know Adu ignorant ignorant to sh you
can't you can't stop me from
speaking we have had nothing but peace
and
B nothing but
peace do it do
itting over everyone please
[Applause]
[Music]
go
everybody what about how the church
left
[Music]
down sit down sit down sit down
please yeah can you sit down
every
we they W coming here today they C
750,000 pieces of Sil and they send
down
[Music]
[Applause]
he's going by bloming War in my home
this yeah his father he's Egyptian
and he went to inside my house and I
feed him from my food when he come to
your house
[Music]
Qui we not going
anywhere just
you
down sit down sit
down
that's
[Music]
it not dead not yet
right that's right I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
question
what